the vacation clock is back guys oh my
God we we added time Chuck you lost some
weight man I think it's I think it's
still right no it was an hour and a half
earlier are you sure about that I'm damn
sure do you have any proof I mean I can
go back and look at the tape where'd you
say check them damn stuff okay y'all
better quit adding time
I think you might be mistaken no no no
no hey man y'all better quit add your
time just like when you add up on the
golf course
offer those numbers I thought your last
name was four yesterday I thought you
were uh I thought you were a mods caddy
yeah come on carry you hey remember that
one he's over there ice in his back now
with commissioning remember that one
hole you hit it in that kitchen
abort Matt abort we were gonna I was
gonna talk about bam but now I want to
get to that last possession for Denver
and they're different philosophies on
this whether to call a timeout or not
Michael Malone chose not to Shaq Murray
gets off a decent shot doesn't go that
happens sometimes what did you think of
that decision you know I think in the
finals you have to be very very
strategic and he decided not to call the
time out Jamal Murray is an exciting
player especially in this building and
he can't hit that shot I thought he was
disrupted right there everybody liked
that side step three iron uncon hit the
front of the rim but again didn't come
down yes you know it's one of those
situations where some people say hey
call the time on get a play and others
say you know what go ahead and go put it
in either Jamal or Joker gym and you
know Jamal had a great shot but he just
missed I mean the you know the one side
is you've got your best one-on-one
player in terms of a guy who can hit a
perimeter three getting the kind of shot
we've seen him hit a million times well
I mean look in that situation you call a
timeout what is he gonna do he's gonna
have two-man game between jokic and
Jamal Murray and look oftentimes coaches
trust their gods their main guys in
those situations uh and he trusted them
and they didn't come through if he hit
that shot we'd be saying something
differently right now but every there's
different you know different ways to
approach it and that's what Michael
Malone in that situation but look it
wasn't that last play right it was
really what Miami did and and quite
frankly to be honest with you I was on
the call and the two losses prior to
this one game four in Minnesota and game
four in Phoenix both games uh in
Minnesota jokic went for 43 and in
Phoenix he went for 53 and tonight 41 41
and then in all the 40 plus games he's
had this season eight of them they're
four and four so Miami it was almost
like they were you know I know Gabe said
that two different looks at him but they
played him straight up pretty much and
they basically said you know what we're
gonna make him beat us but we're gonna
slow down everybody else and you know
what it appears that Gameplay at work
yep and in the meantime Jimmy Butler
took the assignment on Jamal Murray for
much of the game yeah uh Jamar mower is
going to step up but also Michael Porter
Jr got to step up and I thought that uh
kcp made some bonehead decisions filing
Kyle Lowry he filed a couple times on
three-point Shooters can't do that
because you can't make mistakes I think
what Grant said earlier and you said
earlier
and Jeff Van gande was doing a fabulous
job because we're watching the game man
the Denver Nuggets they got to realize
this ain't a regular season game
there was at least five or six occasions
where they doubled and left guys wide
freaking open and you know it sooner or
later he was going to start making shots
the attention to detail Michael Malone
talked about it
and but they didn't listen to me it came
out flat they were playing this game
like a regular season game
and even when they kept it going the the
heat had got their confidence gave
Vincent was terrific bam did well Duncan
Roberts was great and then Jimmy
finished him off but you have to respect
I thought they played this game like a
regular season game tonight well it's
interesting Mike Malone was talking
about after game one this criticism was
we've got to play 48 minutes right and
there were apparent lapses in attention
by Denver tonight and it all started at
the uh last game in the fourth quarter
you know Miami saw some things at work
they were in Dublin you know Joker that
much then but you know Grant you make a
great point we're not going to double
Joker make him you know stop the others
play very very aggressive on defense I
was sitting at the other end the refs 11
giving away they were very very physical
with the guards and the switches on the
pick and roll you know with the joker
every time he come they give him a hard
extra bump and you know he came out
aggressive and you know streus started
him off he came out you know he uh you
know he ended up shooting worked four
for ten yep but he started them off you
know he had some big big threes and you
know the Heat
they lost the league they came back they
lost the lead and they came back and you
know Denver did come out flat and they
should be ashamed because you know all
the talk about you know Championship
ready and you know them being the
favorites they did what they had to do
in game one but Chuck went to Great
point you should never come out flat
when you have the home quarterback it's
inexplicable an NBA Finals game it was
crazy uh how flat they came out and to
me
they were making just too many mental
errors but like from a player standpoint
you had to say yourself the Miami Heat
they who they are
they're going to come out and to get out
to that sloppy of a start uh it was it
was weird for me I was like come on man
you guys are trying to win the
championship and to come out flat
and uh I was I was in shock and like I
say streus got him start it was a really
great team ever by the heat but the
Nuggets deserve some like yo man y'all
dude we're trying to win the
championship and Chuck you're so spot on
I mean think about this Miami they were
in the playing game they're down against
Chicago they lose to the halls in the
first play in game then they got to go
to Milwaukee you know they go to New
York Jimmy gets hurt they get up three
and then all of a sudden Boston wins
three and they have the game seven and
like they've gone through some tough
moments in this postseason so that grit
that we're talking about that resilience
like it's been there it's the Miami Heat
culture but they've gone through that in
this postseason Denver they haven't
faced any of it it's the first this is
that first ever yeah and not only regret
you know I've been saying about Miami
Heat you have to put this team away
right win or lose they're going to play
the same way they're going to shoot the
same shots they're gonna call the same
place when you have this team down you
have to put your foot on the neck and
put them away you can't give them a
chance to come back give him a chance to
give him that life anything can happen
and pick it back on Grant's point I'm
curious to see game three now because
Denver hadn't lost a home game they've
been up in every series obviously and
now you're like uh oh you know that
place in Miami is going to be rocking so
I'm looking forward because you because
like you gotta know you got to raise
your level your intensity every round
you go in the playoffs and for them to
come out like that tonight I'm like oh
man we're going to see what they made of
well it's interesting you know early in
the playoffs
no one was really talking about Denver
you know in the west they were talking
about Phoenix they were talking about
Golden State Warriors and so they always
had this sort of like chip on their
shoulders something to prove but then
all of a sudden like now that they have
a favor now they're the favorite yeah
you know sort of a different ball game
for them and they didn't play great we
talked about they didn't play I got
their best in game one because we
thought they played better tonight we
did we did you know because they come
off the 10-day layoff and they regressed
yeah and they were real happy at the
game one and Mike Malone did a great job
of calling them down hey we haven't done
anything yet I know yeah but it didn't
show on the court though you're right it
didn't it didn't and remember Miami you
know air exposure has been talking about
it throughout the postseason they played
more clutch games those are those games
that are close in the final five minutes
in the regular season than any team of
the week they had more wins in those
situations than any team they've been
battling like this all season long and
it's the postseason
you know their biggest lead the Nuggets
had a chance if they had to kept their
foot to the pedal they had a chance to
blow this game out it's up that way yeah
yeah any minute third quarter they still
had a good size lead but if you let
these guys hang around you see
Vincent Duncan Robinson Jimmy bam I mean
Shaq is 100 right what did I tell you I
have time yeah well I'll tell you who's
gonna win again damn Charles you good
looking Oh you mean something else what
did I tell you half time who's gonna win
the game I'm gonna tell them what you
told me in the locker room the other day
yeah okay
it's probably something about vacation
my body was looking good
I'm sure that's not true no I did I told
him that you're right brother hey hey
hey nobody added anytime yesterday
it was an hour and a half at one point
you gotta check your memory card no I
got a good memory